[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir einen
objekt orte besser gesagt einen
no-wax-ski skate und ich habe mir
gedacht wenn du durch süßigkeiten regal
ok ich wollte ich liebe sie sich keinen
krieg kann hat das genommen was der
lecker findet und das waren happy hippos
und zusätzlich habt ihr mich noch auf
instagram gefragt hey du hast du ne
megageil torte mit deiner hellen
haselnuss clip macht doch noch eine mit
seiner schokohasen aus creme und daher
werde ich die auch integrieren in dem
rezept ich verlegen sie euch natürlich
unten infobox und die meisten sagen dass
die so ein bisschen vom geschmack her
wie ferrero rocher schmeckt da bekomme
ich mal jetzt auf das feedback aber
aktuell hat für erotische die
sommerpause daher kommt dazu auch
irgendwann noch mal ein rezept wenn die
wieder zurück sind ich starte direkt und
schreibe euch alle ganz gerne ab und
nimm die infobox heute nehme ich meinen
tortenring und ich stelle ihn ein auf 23
zentimeter eine ungerade zahl sehr
untypisch tut mir leid falls das im team
angeht aber ich bin 23 fast gerade ganz
gut und dann gebe ich dann noch ein
backpapier unten drunter und dann
starten wir mit dem keks boden
[Musik]
für den keks boden brauchte jetzt
entweder cacau kekse ich habe in meinem
letzten video mit dem mit kakao keksen
sehen ihr habt sie nicht gefunden und
daher gibt es dann ganz einfachen trick
nehmt euch butterkekse die müsste der
wirklich überall finden und gibt einfach
bei kakao dazu und das werde ich jetzt
erst mal fein mahlen
[Musik]
zu den butterkeksen kommen jetzt noch
zerlassene butter und natürlich die
leckeren schoko creme und dann alles
richtig gut miteinander verrühren damit
sich alles zu einer festen masse
verbindet die gebe ich jetzt einmal in
den vorbereiteten tortenring und ich
werde es fest andrücken aber ich werde
auch noch so klein rand hochziehen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt den boden bis zur
weiterverarbeitung einmal in den
kühlschrank gegeben und jetzt machen wir
die creme dafür nämlich auch heute mein
handrührgerät die geht auch superschnell
und ist sehr sehr lecker denn wir haben
kalte schlagsahne doppeln frischkäse
damit ich zum beispiel ganz gerne
philadelphia ich habe etwas machen das
ganze ein bisschen aufzulockern und ich
nehme nur ein bisschen puderzucker denn
der ganze geschmack kommt jetzt noch mal
aus der schoko creme das ganze wird dann
solange verrührt bis es nur gene masse
ergibt und dann werdet ihr merken dass
die sahne dazwischen immer steifer wird
und das ist dann der moment wo wir seine
fest hinzugeben und das dann noch mal
komplett steif schlagen
[Musik]
so die creme ist jetzt fertig und ich
habe auch den boden aus dem kühlschrank
genommen übrigens habe ich die ränder
bewusst so ein bisschen unregelmäßig
gemacht und nicht so schön gerade weil
irgendwie fand ich das ganz charmant und
jetzt gebe ich die komplette cremen
darüber und verstreicht das noch mal
schön blatt
[Musik]
für die glasur habe ich jetzt noch mal
die schokocreme genommen und sie bei 600
watt für 30 sekunden erwerben dadurch
wird sie sehr cremig sie ist schon sehr
cremig aber dadurch kann man sie einfach
noch mal ein bisschen besser verteilen
noch einmal mit dem löffel kurz umrühren
und dann einfach drauf gießen das ist
nicht der schönste moment des tages
gerade beim riecht es auch so gut wenn
es warm ist nochmal
genau jetzt kommst du der beste moment
da ist ne
echt hammermäßig das riecht so heftig
und
jetzt verteilen und dann machen wir noch
ist wieder heute mitgebracht die hipos
obendrauf nun basel ist ich glaube ich
auch genauso wenig fehlen es ist ja
sogar hypo kag wollte ich noch mal
angemerkt haben
[Musik]
ich werde jetzt für die deko noch mal
ein bisschen sahne steif schlagen dann
nämlich einfach kalte schlagsahne ein
bisschen sahne fest und ein bisschen
vanille exakt für den geschmack und das
ganze wieder natürlich mit happy hippos
dekoriert und dann nehme ich noch ein
paar haselnüsse dazu ich werde torte
anschließend über nacht komplett kühlen
damit sie schön sitzen kann eigentlich
reicht noch zwei stunden aber wir haben
es gerade die zeit dann seht ihr morgen
den test mit hamza und mir
[Musik]
meine beste du bist so richtig ländern
also wir machen jetzt dem testet es ich
weiß es die schmecken mit ganze steht
auch so viel zu freundlich aus sie muss
einfach gern haben wir sorgen sollen das
ist eine sehr sehr sehr schöne torte für
mich ernst auch das ist so schön dass
ich bin auch nicht so leicht die show
kann ich habe von der einen seite glatt
gestrichen hier siehst du richtig so es
ist luftig
ich probe von der seite dank wii sowie
soa stürzen es ist übrigens gerade in
irgend 14 uhr morgens oder so ich glaube
kasten toren den letzten jahren gesehen
habe
ich erkläre mahlgut team ist noch ein
keks boden den habe ich einfach
hochgezogen in drin die luftige
schokocreme und um so habe ich auch
nochmal schokohasen gemacht
peter decker weiß dass mich das erinnert
mich ein bisschen an choco fresh weil
das auch so frisch ist
das und das war auch mit dem boden hast
du so ist es so wird die seite die creme
ist richtig es auf der boden ist nicht
zu hart sondern richtig schön knackig
von steuerrechts richtig lecker leute
aber auch das ist eine kuchen so süß
sind ist kaum zucker drin weil die süße
kommt ja aus der schoko creme wobei da
auch schon gezucke anteil reduziert ist
aber es vollkommen perfekt also ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß im
nachmachen markiert mich wenn es
nachgemacht und auf instagram postiert
nicht unbedingt möchte eure grauen dann
haben sie auch ich habe ich mal die ins
lager bekannten in die infobox und
ansonsten ja ich glaube ich nehme doch
mal eigentlich bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]